[Musik]
die millionen metropole istanbul liegt
seit tagen im tiefschlaf es herrscht
ausgangssperre rund um die uhr
und was für besucher idyllisch aussehen
mag ist für türkische bürger weit
weniger romantisch pandemie und
wirtschaftskrise es ist ein ramadan der
härten in diesem jahr
wir sind unterwegs mit dem sozialdienst
den snj im westen istanbuls
normalerweise stehen hier im ramadan
riesige zelte und die ganze
nachbarschaft beim fastenbrechen nach
dem abendgebet zusammenkommt aber
diesmal nicht nicht einmal das gebet in
der moschee ist möglich stattdessen
bringt die stadtverwaltung essen auf
rädern immerhin einer der wenigen
lichtblicke in diesen tagen
meine mutter ist chronisch krank
sie braucht medikament und ständige
untersuchungen aber die krankenhäuser
sind nur noch für pandemie fälle
zuständig für uns einfacher bürger ist
das gesundheitssystem nicht gut
die zahl der korona infizierten vor
allem in istanbul ist im letzten monat
nahezu explodiert die sieben tage
incidents erreichte rekordwerte von 900
kliniken sind überlastet die regierung
zog letzten freitag die notbremse 17
tage lockdown mit vielen ausnahmen für
ihsan delic war das keine gute nachricht
sein kebab restaurant in kadiköy auf der
asiatischen seite istanbuls ist seit
wochen geschlossen
14 mitarbeiter will ihn nicht entlassen
aber es wird schwer
im ramadan wäre sein restaurant
normalerweise ausgebucht aber in diesem
jahr nichts absolut nichts zu beginn des
ramadan mussten wir zwei goldarmbänder
meiner frau verkaufen
die waren eigentlich als rücklagen
gedacht nur damit ich das restaurant
nicht schließen muss
irgendwie durchhalten sagt seine frau
nach idee die mit den töchtern das essen
für das fastenbrechen vorbereitet die
nachbarn die sonst im ramadan dazustoßen
fehlen diesmal private einladungen
verboten zu groß ist die
infektionsgefahr bei der ersten welle
waren viele noch gelassen das hat sich
geändert seit fast jede familie
betroffen ist
mein bruder ist schwer erkrankt zwei
schwestern zum glück nur leicht die
regierung setzt auf schutzimpfungen um
die pandemie zu bekämpfen
mehr als 24 millionen dosen
hauptsächlich chinesischer impfstoff
wurden bereits verabreicht kostenlos
diese patienten hier im
gesundheitszentrum kategorie die schon
zum zweiten mal geimpft wird ist dankbar
mein mann hatte sich nach der ersten
impfung infiziert wegen der impfung aber
zum glück nur mit leichten symptomen
der lock down trifft vor allem den
einzelhandel und privathaushalte weil
die wirtschaft ohnehin schon schwer
angeschlagen ist wurden ganze branchen
wie industrie baulogistik ausgenommen
hier wird weiter gearbeitet kleine
händler und selbständige sind deshalb
sauer
sie mussten letzten donnerstagabend für
fast drei wochen die rollläden
herunterlassen
in 40 jahren arbeit hat der schneider
ismael türkers vieles erlebt aber das
hier sagt er hätte man doch vermeiden
können
noch im märz hatten sie gelockert sagte
er gegen den rat der experten jetzt
plötzlich lockdown der auch noch
schlecht organisiert sei die behörden
haben kurz vor dem lotter und allen
erlaubt nach der natur ian aufzubrechen
wer noch nichts hatte er steckt sich
garantiert da an und bringt das ganze
wieder zurück hier her und dann müssen
wir wieder einen monat dicht machen
nicht nur der schneider hat bei diesen
bildern vom letzten donnerstag den kopf
geschüttelt millionen istanbuler auf den
autobahnen an flughäfen und busbahnhöfen
nichts wie weg ab ins ferienhaus oder
zur familien die provinz er der lockdown
über land reisen verbietet allerdings
gilt das nicht für alle touristen sind
von den einschränkungen ausgenommen
auch wenn die strände an der türkischen
riviera gegen korona ziemlich leer
bleiben
familie senger aus dortmund genießt den
urlaub in alanya ganz ohne auflagen
in deutschland gehen die schulisch auf
haben wir unser urlaub halt verlängert
weil touristen haben es sehr bequem aber
man kann hier raus auch wochenende die
ausgangssperren nicht von daher ist
angenehm
tourismus ist ein wichtiger
devisenbringer für die türkei aber diese
ungleichbehandlung im lockdown stößt
vielen türken übel auf von einem urlaub
am strand jedenfalls kann familien die
liga derzeit nicht einmal träumen
tochter htg ist eigentlich
kindergärtnerin
sie jobbt wegen geschlossener schulen
aber als kassiererin im supermarkt
selbst das zuckerfest der bayram zum
ende des fastenmonats wird diesmal
freudlos wir haben sonst immer die
verwandten besucht da gab es großes
picknick mit vielen gästen aber jetzt
bleiben alle zuhause wir werden mit
verwandten und freunden videoanrufe
machen
das war's dann ruft der muezzin zum
gebet für heute hat bei familie die zeit
das fasten ein ende
die korona sorgen aber noch nicht kann
dann war schon mal schön ab